bernard werber bernard werber werber
werber werber des rebelles mais en fait
ils tous les livres de bernard werber là
mêmes celui-là qui ressort qu'au mois
d'octobre
ouais mais aujourd'hui je sors le blog
et les résultats du concours salue les
menthe à l'eau si vous me suivez sur
twitter sur instagram ou sur facebook
vous avez pu voir qu'il ya quelques
jours j'ai rencontré bernard werber et
bien aujourd'hui on va pas parler de lui
mais on va parler avec lui d'abord de
son spectacle qui va se jouer demain et
qui est déjà complet je crois mais
surtout de tous attention je vous mets
juste un court extrait de 15 minutes
puisque je sais que les vidéos trop
longues sur la chaîne c'est compliqué et
surtout parce que nous discutions
ensemble a duré 40 minutes
alors si vous voulez voir les autres
moment de la discussion que vous avez
raté vous pourrez à la fin
cliquez dans le lien que je mets dans le
descriptif j'ai fait une vidéo juste
pour ça je les mises en ont répertorié
est allé dans le descriptif dans le
descriptif vous trouverez aussi une
vidéo non répertorié que je vais faire
dans quelques minutes devant vous avec
les résultats du concours que j'avais
fait sur la deuxième vidéo de pi voilà
tout est dit alors maintenant place à
l'un des échanges les plus intéressants
qui est sur cette chaîne depuis le 1er
janvier
et donc je suis arrivé chez bernard
lerhe gars merci de nous recevoir
infernal si vous êtes vous heureux de ce
que j'ai compris c'est bon on est dans
un spectacle de moment présent puisqu'il
ya des choses qui vont être improvisé
jusque là je me trompe ou pas vraiment
fait tout le spectacle improvisé tous
les spectacles moment où le rideau
s'ouvre
je ne sais pas ce que je veux dire c'est
alors sont prises de risques énormes
on l'a connu dans l'humour quelque chose
qu'on fait en humour et en réalité il ya
toujours une trame il connaissances
entre les comédiens qui font qu a prise
de risque et pas si grosse noire pour un
seul en scène c'est la première fois que
j'entends parler de ça et du coup
j'aimerais bien ça qu'elle était
motivation à personne la motivation en
fait j'ai fait avec les gens de la
veillée notamment patrick boos et damien
maric j'avais fait une apparition sur
scène sur l'idée raconter l'histoire la
plus extraordinaire que vous êtes arrivé
j'avais raconté la première la première
histoire celle
de la corse et manger rencontre j'ai
raconté cette histoire je me suis aperçu
d'abord qu'il y avait une intensité
d'ecoute énorme plus importante que
celle que j'ai dans mes conférences une
salle bondée et au mans j'ai raconté
l'histoire je me suis aperçu que ça
fonctionne exactement comme j'essaie de
faire en héros monde c'est-à-dire jeunes
je les tiens en haleine avec du suspense
et je les fais rire de temps en temps et
je m'en dire je suis branché sur le
groupe
je le perçois et il se plaint dialogue
entre le public et moi et cette chose me
manque beaucoup d'enfants et d'écriture
passe quand j'écris j'imagine les gens
qu'ils vont lire le lit les vents rire
là ils vont être inquiet là ils vont se
demander vont penser que c'est celui-là
l'assassin ils vont penser que le trésor
caché là mais je ne sais pas si ça va
marcher
et là je vois en direct il m'est arrivé
d'autres histoires extraordinaires
bon je vais pas dévoiler tous les amis
en faisant se pâmer je me suis retrouvé
à tu dis les fourmis en afrique ça c'est
connu mais ce que les gens savent pas à
lui me suis retrouvé dans une tribu qui
était cannibales et au moment où j étais
ils ont leur sorcier qui est mort et
pour l'élection du nouveau sorcier
ils sont allé chasser la tribu d'à côté
et donc je me suis retrouvé à nous lire
le groupe de scientifiques français en
dépens d'angers mais on a assisté à un
truc qui qu'on voit dans les films de
tarzan d'entre eux et c'était vraiment
vraiment alors je raconte exactement ce
que j'ai vu évidemment je n'ai pas
assisté à tout mais après elle mitch
n'ont pas je ne juge pas les gens ne me
croient mais pendant ce temps suffisant
de détail pour qu'on comprenne que c'est
ce que c'est ce qui est entré dans le
cadre de ma bible le fait que tu fasses
la démarche d'aller sur scène en tant
que de passer d'un raconteur un compteur
c'est un storytelling en deux matches le
promu avait jamais fait mais en fait ça
devient une évidence
ben pour moi ça devient une évidence je
pense que tu vas être trop lié à ça
alors c'est pas si demander si bien que
tu me dis ça parce que j'ai eu un super
prix touche quand le rideau sont ouverts
dans ma tête et tout vous regardez il y
avait cette idée
bon maintenant tu as intérêt à être bon
si l'autre est ridicule
cette idée a engrangé sais pas si tu as
déjà eu ça peut aussi aimer tabriquet
devant plein de gens en plus qui ont
payé pour te voir donc c'est pas bien
donc ça arrive je ne sais pas ce que je
veux dire et puis je démarre et après ça
devait être la première demi heure
je m'arrête tout
10% j'y prends du plaisir et je
racontais l'histoire
je voyais des gens qui m'écoutait qui me
regardait je me suis dit ça me plaît de
faire ça mais ça me plaît dans l'absolu
là pour gagner ma vie pas pour la gloire
juste parce que c'est ma fonction comme
un oiseau chanteur il a besoin de
chanter il ne fait pas avec un objectif
il me semble que j'étais à ma place et
maintenant j'allais plus loin je pense
que tout écrivain devrait faire cet
exercice il y en a pas se contenter de
l'écrit est passée à l'oral ne serait ce
que pour vérifier
est ce qu il sait tenir en haleine en
direct une salle ou pas l'objet d'une
vraie question aussi je me pose le
budget mais qu'il allait faire de la
scène d'expliquer dans un tel ouvrage je
crois qu'à un moment donné tu construis
l'été roman un petit peu en architecture
dite cathéter qui a été une source
d'inspiration pour construire moi mes
propres spectacles lire et du coup je me
dis ah là bas je me demandais si tu
avais essayé d'appliquer ça à ton
spectacle à part une réponse la réponse
est j'ai essayé oui j'ai renoncé
oui aussi d'accord mais tu as essayé
c'était une démarche peut-être parce que
même quand je te parle là quand je quand
je développe une pensée je pense tout le
temps dans une structure de type
cathédrale
parce que c'est un défaut et ça me pose
un énorme problème c'est que de nos
jours le mode de conversation c'est
comme comme au tennis et tac au tac donc
moyen moment si on veut faire un tac tac
tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac tac
tac tac tac c'est à dire développer une
histoire l'a développé tous ses biens sa
demande à l'autre d'être un peu plus
patient et de nos jours les gens n'ont
plus cette patiente attendre une
histoire développée et je crois
d'ailleurs non que je te dis ça je me
semble je crois qu'ils ont monté ce
spectacle je me suis dit tiens je ne
prends un temps d'écouté où je vais vous
développez une histoire en entier
tranquillement il ça va être ça le
spectacle
je crois que depuis que je suis petit je
me sens frustré de ne pas trouver dans
le regard et dans les coupes des autres
n'est ce pas suffisamment larges plus
puissent développer quelque chose d'un
peu complexe voilà donc j'ai fait par
écrit et maintenant je fais à l'oral
mais donc il ya tout le temps une
structure en général je fais c'est plus
qu'une cathédrale
pour moi la vraie structure c'est le
corps humain c'est à dire que dans
n'importe quoi
une histoire un système ya déjà une tête
un ventre et les pieds donc et menin
cathedra cassin
si on regarde les formes des cathédrales
sa forme il ya les deux bras voilà le
coeur il ya la tête il ya les jambes et
quand j'ai créé une histoire
je commence par faire la ligne de la
ligne de narration principal qui prend
la bonne vertébrale la tête qui va être
la chute
donc c'est à dire le moment où doit voir
la révélation et les pieds qui est
l'endroit où ça commence à monter
donc ça démarre au pied ça monte d'un
clown vertébrale se termine à la tête
après les deux bras musclés te le dire
ces deux éléments histoires parallèles
qui ne sont pas indispensables mais
qu'équilibre l'histoire une fois que
j'ai mon seul être qui tient et jantes
est clairement qu'ils tiennent
ajoute les organes donc le coeur
l'estomac le foie cervelle et ça c'est
les grandes scènes originales
j'essaie de faire des scènes qu'on n'a
pas vu ailleurs on s'en fiche et surtout
l'europe l'originalité fiançailles
une fois que j'ai squelette plus organes
je mets les mus que ça fait c'est normal
qu'ils font a lancé mon personnage
ça va être le voyage histoire d'amour
les décomptes petits conflits tout ça ça
va faire le music
une fois que j'ai tout ça que j'ai testé
plusieurs fois je me suis la peau et les
gens ne voient que la peau comme
maintenant je ne vois que ta peau je ne
vois pas tant cela coûtait miss météores
galles et vous toi tu vois pareil que ma
poule
mais tout ça ne tient que parce qu'en
dessous il ya toute une mécanique et
quand je regarde un film quand je
regarde même une pièce de théâtre je me
demande tout le temps
est-ce que ce que les tiens qu'est-ce
que les organes sont extraordinaires
est-ce que les muscles sont bien foutus
et est ce que la peau va bien lorsque je
ne juge pas eu neuf sur sa peau dont on
pourrait dire sur son apparence sur son
style sur la juste sur la paix l'aspect
extérieur je ne joue sur
l'infrastructure caché qui maintient
ensemble donc le spectacle c'est jeudi
soir s'il reste encore des places vous
mais un lien dans le descriptif vous
pouvez cliquer là il ya de ça contre
lille reste des risques des places sur
sur la piste de théâtre ah oui qui va
démarrer le 22 et la salle de 700
personnes c'est le salaire alors s'il a
vu le plus d'avis oui oui papa cet été
de l'année les bienvenus au paradis
machin effet que de bien
au paradis et nos amis les humains nous
aiment les humains c'est jean christophe
barc qui reprend ça c'est l'audiovisuel
les autres formes de récit que ce soit
le théâtre cour mettra tout ça c'est
votre jour intéressé d'aller voir
je crois que on peut pas rester dans son
art se dire bon ben j'ai tout le temps
faire la même chose je trouve en faire
des livres puis je m'intéresse pas mais
la vidéo ni ni aux séries au fil il faut
aller voir
quitte à se tromper quitte à ne pas être
bon mais au moins testé c'est vrai que
moi tout au long de ma vie de jeune
adulte adultes je t'ai vu évoluer avec
la bande dessinée cité existe je crois à
l'époque je sais pas s'il a démarré dans
la bande dessinée
ma culture est lamentable c'est
l'addition enfants du métal hurlant
quand j'ai découvert métal et en or je
me suis arrêté je me suis dit tout d'un
coup il ya la culture qui vient de faire
un bond
c'est devant mes yeux ce numéro 1 de
métal hurlant avec moi bus druyer
l'époque il y avait mille admirer tous
les grands étaient réunis mais là dedans
et c'était de la bande dessinée pour
adultes donc il ya du sexe la violence
de la science fiction
on parlait déjà de 10 qui parlait déjà
de tous les grands d'asie mot fait tout
et il est couverture extraordinaire et
je me suis dit ok je crois qu'en france
on est en train d'être à la tête d'un
système est bien plus tard soit des
américains ont repris le sida mairie des
films qui sont sortis mais de métal
hurlant et je crois qu'à un moment les
américains sont dit mon sens la
créativité
elle est en france et en belgique elle
est sûre c'est des projets comme ça
aussi beaucoup de tweets end je pensais
les auteurs donc qu'ils étaient des
auteurs extraordinaire et ils ont
inventé de nouveaux rêves ils ont
inventé de nouveaux visuels et donc
jacquelin foncine on faisait des choses
dans l'esprit métal hurlant quand
j'étais au lycée
ça s'appelait la soupe a dozen puis avec
lens est sorti du lycée c'est devenu
l'euphorie et après c'est un scénario
aux deux favoris qui s'appelait fourni
qui a donné le roman un fait drôle mais
j'ai démarré dans la bande dessinée est
en mode d'expression j'ai toujours
trouvé un point commun entre ce que
décrivent et les bandes dessinées dans
le sang sont en fin de chaque page avait
toujours assez d'haleine pour retourner
la silhouette amour leur point commun
ils mais restait ainsi truc de la bande
dessinée c'est de faire les storyboards
quand il ya des batailles notamment et
dans les fourmis avait a bataillé
coquelicots et et après il ya toujours
une petite vie un petit moment et des
fouilles qui rendent les unes dans les
happy man est un atout note
ils se battent en chorégraphie dans
l'espace je fais je fais des storyboards
en venant les valeurs de cadres donc je
vais mettre les plans panoramiques les
plans serrés les combats avec les les
lumières et tout et les gens vont voir
l'écriture mais ce qu'ils savent pas ce
que moi j'ai l'image et
presque je monte à zhao filles jouent
avec les mots donner des valeurs de
cadres il suffit de dire ses yeux était
étincelant oussama s'approcher à deux
boutons et on a une valeur de cadres et
si on dit la foule avant ça dans la
vallée on a une automatique mans ils
veulent regarder ces démos mais sa
fabrique de du rêve dans la tête de ceux
qui le reçoivent
est ce qu'il y a un projet défini pour
la continuité des romans est ce qu'il ya
une sorte de but
il ya deux choses dans ma tête il est
conscient et l'inconscient l'inconscient
oui un projet mais le conscient je ne
connais pas donc je fais des livres
c'est j'empile des briques et
l'inconscience et que ça à faire le mur
il sait la forme d'humeur mais le
conscience des justes bien j'ai fini une
bride pas sur la brède suivante
donc je pense quelque chose en moi quel
plan global
mais moi je ne les plains et donc la
main même même la brique demain les
chats qui va sortir en octobre
moi j'étais au team bricka qui a surgi
par hasard j'ai fait un roman j'ai fait
un roman de type jules verne et quand
j'ai relu je me suis ça ressemble un peu
à ce que j'avais mis dans le ciem
sommeil donc je suis en tout pas vous
proposer des choses qui se ressemblent
donc romance et déjà 600 pages j'ai mis
de côté toujours sortir un jour
peut-être en tournée des boues pour vous
faire autrement et j'ai fait à toute
vitesse demain les chats comme un livre
d'urgence pour parler de ce que je
voyais de ce que je sentais de mon
époque mais racontée par un chat
plus précisément par une chatte qui est
extrêmement comment dire cynique mais
présente mais en même temps plein de
bonne volonté un pour les hommes donc
c'est un personnage étrange qui est pas
vraiment positif une entrée qui j'espère
est très amusant et en écrivant le roman
j'avais mis comme comme compagnon de vie
de ma chapelle basse terre
un personne qui s'appelait socrates à
l'époque mais ce cas je me suis c'est
trop facile c'est chaque fois qu'un
philosophe on l'appelle socrates
j'ai cherché un autre nom que je fais
vite à gorges s'est passé détaille les
comme ça je suis allé voir la ville de
ce bonhomme qui vivait en moins 500 en
jésus-christ et là je suis tombé en
pâmoison
ce type est le type le plus
extraordinaire de toute l'histoire de
l'humanité il celui qui a inventé mot
philosophie c'est lui qui a inventé ou
mathématiques
c'est lui qui a inventé la gamme
musicale
donc c'est toute notre culture vient de
ce bonhomme pythagore qui n'a laissé
aucun écrit mais c'est tous ces élèves
qui ont raconté qu'ils étaient le
bonhomme et ses extras et donc qu'il ya
eu en même temps cette idée parler de
l'humanité après ils regardent d'une
chatte et parler de pythagore qui comme
un type qui essaie de sortir l'humanité
de l'obscurité pour l'amener vers la
lumière
définitivement donc ma chatte est
éclairé par pythagore et j'espère que
l'anjou au l'humanité pigera que dans ce
bonhomme pythagore
il y a il n'y a pas juste théorème de
pythagore qui est vraiment un élément
anecdotique de sa vie il ya un code de
vie il était végétarien il pratiquait
la danse de sport le yoga est incroyable
un rallye carnation ils s'étaient c'est
le premier qui a créé une école dans
lequel les femmes les esclaves
l'étranger été admis ce qui à l'époque
était révolutionnaire et c'est un type
qui a tout le temps à une sorte faire
une oeuvre d'art de vinci mais en plus
ce qui a créé une école comme seul ainsi
avait créé une école pour qu'ils aient
d'autres léonard de vinci et socrate et
platon sont des élèves d'élèves de
pythagore
il sort le 1er octobre et aujourd'hui on
n'est pas le 1er octobre est gelée dans
mes mains voilà que je vous fais voir on
vous donnera ainsi envie mais oui je
dois faire gazer de plaisir je vous mets
toutes les infos pour ce qui concerne
bernard werber dans le descriptif de la
vidéo que ce soit la pièce de théâtre au
palace que soit la sortie du livre les
autres livres les anciens livres si vous
n'avez fait que découvrir aujourd'hui
vous avez dit apte pour thomas a tapé
mais vous allez cliquer c'est sûr et
puis et puis le spectacle peut-être
renaîtra de ses cendres
si ça marche bien
si ça marche ce que je dis je le refais
reçoit déjà prévu quelques dates en
province à province
mais je me rappelle plus ou moins cinq
grandes villes que qui sont prévus dans
une sorte de tournée et puis pour le
reste bas je m'adapte et si je sens
qu'ils demandent avec ça leur fait
plaisir et que ça m'amuse je continue
puis je sens que ça fonctionne moins
d'heures je serais tombé je trouverais
autre chose mais pour l'instant voilà
c'est après demain ça va je connais la
pièce eh bien tu te souhaite un gros
maire pour tous et merci encore d'avoir
accueilli 10e départ le soir et il m'a
appelé en disant mais si c'est bon tu
viens merci beaucoup
et combien pour le 15 mai je serai assez
à toi sale une chance pour tes
spectacles aussi merci j'espère que vous
avez apprécié ce moment autant que moi
j'ai donc eu la chance de me faire
offrir un des dix livres qu'ils avaient
déjà rempli sortie qu'il m'a gentiment
dédicacé je précise quand même si jamais
faut le dire que c'est pas un placement
de produit en fait je l'avais contacté
sur twitter il m'a gentiment répondu et
a la base je voulais lui poser deux
trois questions après son spectacle de
jeudi
mais à la place il a eu la gentillesse
de me contacter et de me proposer de
venir chez lui directement le soir même
à 22 heures ils étaient plutôt tard ce
qui montre quand même le côté très sympa
du mec
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo dites
moi dans les commentaire quel est votre
livre préféré parmi tout ce qu'a fait
bernard werber comme ça on va comparer
un petit peu nos goûts je vous mets donc
dans le descriptif le lien pour les
résultats du concours pour la vidéo les
changes en entier pour le spectacle pour
le têt voilà vous avez tout il ya juste
à dérouler n'oubliez pas de mettre un
pouce en l'air si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo que vous en voulez d'autres du
genre n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
avant de partir et rendez vous demain à
17 heures parce que mentale blog c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an
ciao je joue mon spectacle en entier le
23 septembre la garenne colombes c'est
la date la plus proche de paris
jamais vous voulez venir sinon il ya
toutes les dates de tournée sur mon site